we came and said
scanning and identifying static
vulnerabilities is just the beginning
what people really care about is
whether those
thousands of vulnerabilities that we
find whether they're actually
exploitable and if it's exploitable
prove me so people want to see that we
can actually exploit a vulnerability to
then get to a crown jewel
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hello stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're going to be talking
to the ceo of one of the most hyper
growing startups in cyber security
called pantera in pen testing but we're
going to be discussing his journey from
being an executive salesman to the ceo
of a cyber security startup meet amitay
razan the ceo of pantera amitai is an
experienced ceo specializing in growing
early stage tech ventures from no
revenue or early revenue to tens of
millions in arr across regions and
verticals as pantera ceo he's led
exponential growth since january of 2018
to becoming the de facto market leader
in automated security validation through
three funding rounds from awc ventures
the blackstone group and insight
partners the most prominent cyber
security investor of our time
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders the ceo of
pantera how are you
thank you michael it's a pleasure being
here indeed
see open terra we've just changed the
name from sizes so some people who
probably know us still as sizes but we
like the new name better although we
have lots of sentiments with the old one
obviously we're going to talk about how
it's relevant to exactly what you're
doing and i love it and amitai not the
traditional path of a ceo of a cyber
security company captain of the infantry
unit idc tel aviv university mba
executive mba at kellogg
then going on a sales route
and climbing the ladder there to to
leading sales at some great companies
and then
being an entrepreneur and creating a
cyber security company how does that
happen
yes so this is a great question and
indeed it's not like the typical route
i'm not like one of those guys
like 24 25 year old out of 8200 right i
was in different eight something unit
but not in a different part of the idf
so we are not a typical route
um
actually if i try to kind of to
understand how it all happened
uh to me the whole
journey kind of starts in new york city
i was um
just after my army service
um you know an officer traveling touring
the world like all of us
here in israel trying to have fun right
after the army
found myself in new york city talking to
a friend
that kind of convinced me to take a
sales job at a company called the jewish
yellow pages believe it or not that was
um in in queens boulevard new york i'm
like the year is 1999 and why do i know
about sales and about new york right i'm
just like a tourist that just got like
some some temporary visit to do that
so um i find myself with no preparation
running in the streets of new york
trying to convince physicians you know
chiropractors pediatricians dentists to
buy yellow yellow pages advertisements
in a in a well-known directory called
the jewish yellow pages right
um that was pre-internet 1999.
so to survive in new york and to be able
to go to the new york knicks games and
to do like a coast to coast trip and to
go to the best parties in town
and and to have fun i had to survive and
i had to make some good money and find
and do something that i'm happy with so
i kind of um
learned how to survive
uh in that job as a sales guy so i was
you know topping sales in this company
selling two three yellow pages
advertisements a day
for i did it for half a year and then i
said okay it's enough now i can go to
israel and and study law and businesses
i planned then i was promoted to be a
head of an office so i was 23 year old i
was running an office with like 20
something employees i had two cars
living their life uh and and that's kind
of where i realized that that um that
sales should be part of what i do when i
grow up
uh that's kind of how i that's kind of
how my career started
very non-traditional i came back to
israel went to idc
i studied learning businesses i always
planned
i was admitted to one of the best firms
in the country gornitsky and company i
was sure i'm going to be a lawyer in one
in like a great office or at least start
my career as a lawyer but as i was about
to do my internship
something didn't feel right for me i
mean to be a lawyer i kind of remember
those great days in new york where i
really enjoyed selling and managing
sales guys and and all this like vibe
that didn't really kind of um connect to
the to the life as being an intern or a
lawyer
so um i was lucky enough to be
identified by super derivatives
that was in 2003-45
it was like the iron source or the jfrog
or the monday.com of the time it was one
of the best companies in israel in high
tech
so i took a job
and i started there as a
as a as a sales guy for the nordic
region after i finished my i learned
business degree
so the kind of they gave me they told me
hey amitai you're not spoiled you've
been in the army in an elite infantry
unit so why won't you go and sell in
iceland norway and like in sweden
and i said okay i can say i've done it
in new york
but then the ceo there told me david
gerson he said amitai you know
us fintech you know veterans we know
that people like you were just starting
you would have really like hard time at
the beginning because you're not from
the industry you just graduated from idc
you're very young it would take you some
time to pick up and understand really
delay of the land in sales right in
enterprise sales
it took me a year and a half to kind of
uh be the company's top performer which
i kept for a few years
um all of that selling from you know in
the nordic region from tel aviv so
flying to reykjavik
uh like norway sweden etc
for five six seven years that's how i
started my career um and that was like
in enterprise sales hardcore
um without any expertise in derivatives
pricing systems analytics i learned
everything on the fly but that's that's
not a traditional path to start with for
people who today run cyber security
companies i guess i'm i'm starting to
see a pattern here well i guess it's all
thanks to those jewish yellow pages in
the end
give me a few tips
in sales it's not every day that i get
to talk to somebody who who got to sell
jewish yellow pages and then got to sell
from tel aviv to the nordic
places and
and become a top performer within a year
and a half after not knowing anything
tell me a little bit about what you
learned yeah so so to me the profession
of sales was always the profession of
understanding the human's brain to me it
was always like a mind challenge a game
challenge uh it was really never about
the money although as they say if you're
good at what you do you make money in
this business
it was always the drive to um you know
when i kind of came across a prospect i
always told myself well this guy doesn't
know
but in 20 30 days this guy is going to
spend hundred thousand dollars with me
he just doesn't know it i do and it's
gonna take me 30 days and certain things
to do so that hundred thousand dollars
flow from his pocket to the company's
pocket so it was always about the brain
challenge what do you do
in time zero so that in time you know
whatever
30 days 60 90 days
um you get your stuff you know uh uh as
you wanted to and you're able to
convince and and convey the value
proposition all of that happening like
in the middle but it's really a brain a
brain game
of how you uh kind of convince someone
who's a complete stranger to follow uh
your paradigm and and what you want to
achieve
in the thailand it's good for you now
whether it's cyber security fintech
advertisement of yellow pages that's
just these are nuances these are details
at the end of the day
it starts and ends with with uh with
this kind of mind game
what what leads you to think of
penetration testing and the simulating
cyber attacks
as uh you know as an important part of
the cyber ecosystem today let alone
obviously deciding to start a company
yeah so so i just kind of take a step
back before that if you don't mind so
after super derivatives i i was vp of
sales for you know two israeli startups
uh the one where i spend most of the
time is earnings which is today unicorn
where inside partners have lately just
invested you know they're a great
company i was very lucky to be their vp
of sales for four years so after i've
done four vp of sales roles the second
one at this young startup called call
view
i got a call from uh the two founders of
pantera then sizes i didn't found this
business
it's it's the it's alright liberals and
eric feingold that were the founders and
they kind of found me on the kellogger
canadi network so i did my executive mba
there at kellogg and they called the
program head and they asked her you know
a ceo because we need somebody with
enterprise sales expertise and i was
just giving a lecture at kellogg about
the international sales management
and late back then the director of the
program told them yeah call me
so i spoke to the founders and i said
wow you know this is this is awesome a
technology that with a click of a button
launches
real cyber attacks against
a company's infrastructure without
installing agents without any game just
the real deal just like that
so ike liberals on which is my my
partner in crime to this journey the cto
and the inventor behind pantera
you know looked me in the eyes and said
this is going to be the next big thing
and i've never seen such a termination
in a founder's eyes like i saw in arik
and i said this is the guy i want to
work with
because i never i've never written even
one line of code in my life
but i scale businesses from nothing to
tens of millions of dollars that's what
i do for a living
and arik
is an amazing entrepreneur an amazing
technologist so together me and eric we
kind of went on this journey
now we're 130 employees at pinterest wow
selling tens of millions of dollars all
of that was achieved in three and a half
years we have people in 10 countries
a big office of almost 35 people in in
the east coast of the united states
with 30 people selling in nine european
countries working for us i mean all over
with big r d
um and research teams that that came
from elite units of the israeli defense
forces people that came from rx unit
which is called the special ones it's a
very special unit of um of uh cyber
researchers that were basically
challenged with the task of infiltrating
uh the
most kind of lucrative assets of the
country of israel uh before the bad guys
do that
so ari kind of came with this narrative
i joined him to to make this
great idea a real business that is today
a market leader
unbelievable
what's similar
in your time as a salesman
in the different
organizations whether it be you know
fintech or whatever or or in cyber
security what's
what what are you drawing from your
previous experiences that's helping you
channel this you know this energy and
this understanding into the cyberspace
yeah so so i think that while cyber is
something that that a that for for a
sales guy or for a marketeer or for a i
would i would say that product
management r d you can't teach that they
need to come with that already from home
but um
while that is something that you can
learn so how to pitch a cyber product or
how to promote a cyber product what you
cannot teach
is passion and drive and and hunger so i
think what i take with me from my days
as a sales guy
uh it's all about determination all
about hunger all about
hearing from investors and ecosystem
that a startup is a business that is
that is determined to to die unless you
make it and you don't
so
when i kind of heard that it's again
it's in against all odd situation which
is the the situation i got into the
beginning
i loved it and i think that that's a
very common thing across all the places
where i worked at it was like an against
all odd situation
uh and and i love that
um i would say that um
just like super derivatives and earnings
we have a product here that adds tons of
value that you don't need to
uh hard sell so people understand today
in the around summer age people don't
need to be you know don't need to be
hard sold to understand that one needs
to attack themselves like the bad guys
to really understand how the bad guys
think and operate right so so the fact
we sell on real value and the company
didn't invent the product and then look
for buyers to satisfy the founders kind
of uh um
idea which is detachable reality in this
case it's a different situation where uh
credit to the founders that thought
about a solution
that the market was already already
hungry for so when i joined it was quite
easier because the product already
answered the real need we didn't need to
invent a need and then ask people to
believe that the need exists
wow and so give me a broad overview on
penetration testing today at scale and
and how you're working with pantera and
you know in so many countries and and
tens of millions of dollars in sales to
to help them
feel more secured and test by
simulations that they really are secure
yeah so i start with the end i mean
we're actually very proud of it we're
not doing any simulations so while
others in our kind of ecosystem would
actually go the agent's approach deploy
lots of agents in the network and then
provide them with the playbook
and then run some simulation pantera is
very proud of not running any simulation
we would actually attack the enterprise
like the bad guys would
with one exception that we come with no
malicious intentions but besides the
malaysians intent and besides the fact
we do no harm it's exactly like the bad
guys so we are the whole company here
and the reason why we have the best
investors in the world like the
blackstone group and inside partners
and the execution is all thanks to the
fact that this is a no simulation type
of business
and and i think that what the what's
interesting here is
that we're disrupting an old market of
vulnerability assessment vulnerability
management
as part of which buyers were used to
just
scan for static vulnerabilities in the
network that are a result of legacy
windows products like windows 8 windows
xp windows 10 etc etc and and just
scanning and identifying vulnerabilities
up until we came and started our play
was the thing
we came and said
scanning and identifying static
vulnerabilities is just the beginning
what people really care about is
whether those
thousands of vulnerabilities that we
find whether they're actually
exploitable and if it's exploitable
prove me so people want to see that we
can actually exploit a vulnerability to
then get to a crown jewel so pantera
actually exploits vulnerabilities
whether static or network
misconfiguration
aka dynamic vulnerabilities we exploit
them we get to crown jewels and we show
the buyer hey this is your cfo's left
this is the cfo's laptop this is your
financial report this is the swift uh uh
user and password this is this is crazy
stuff and we put our hands on it in five
seven minutes
now what do you want to do mr buyer so
it's very provocative it's very much in
your face but in a good way people
appreciate it
at the beginning they say ah you
wouldn't find so much because deloitte
were just here then as we try as we find
stuff and as we do it very fast they go
go pantera go go go because they're
happy that our product actually
identifies stuff and then at the end we
don't need to do a hard sell it's just
very trivial
wow
sounds crazy and so when when you start
talking to to people now it's more the
sales side when you start talking to new
customers do they understand from the
get-go
if you're just talking to them about
what you're doing let's say an executive
in a big company do they do they feel
comfortable with this idea or do you
have because obviously you know from the
cyberspace i get it but but do
executives that are not coming from the
cyberspace let's say institutions like
banks or electricity companies these
sorts of companies that are very very
sensitive to these topics do they
understand what you're doing
yeah so great question
i would say up until you know two three
years ago
run somewhere and and the likelihood of
a small medium enterprise absorbing a
ransomware attack was wasn't really
there so when when you talk to today to
executives in small retailers small
supermarkets medium-sized law firms in
the uk switzerland germany three years
ago ransomware attacks in cyber attacks
were not for them it was the business of
goldman sachs and capital one and
equifax and those you know very big
companies from america
lately uh we're seeing board of
directors and ceos asking their csos
what are we doing for ransomware we gave
you all this money you spent two three
million dollars on firewalls
anti-viruses edr's what do we do for
ransomware i don't want to make a
headlines tomorrow do we challenge
ourselves like the bad guys or almost
like the bad guys so now that joe biden
just went on went publicly and said and
calls enterprise of the world do third
party pentests the president of the
united states
i mean that's like the best pre-sale
activity that this guy that our company
could have expected
i i've never heard you know uh ovi
rivlin or benjamin netanyahu telling
enterprises go and do third party
pentests but joe biden does that he just
went to the like it's uh addressing the
union and said hey all the ransomware
attacks are like the modern terrorists
go challenge yourself like the bad guys
so that that has given us huge back wind
so now i mean when joe biden does your
pre-sales you don't need the pre-sales
team right
i mean
i i i love the energy and like and i can
see why you're so successful you're
selling jewish uh yellow pages i i love
it and i love the story and obviously
i'm a big advocate of of what you're
doing and and that every enterprise
needs to doesn't shouldn't not not only
should do pentesting but has to do pen
testing it's for the greater good and at
the end for me as an end consumer living
life it's it's i i really appreciate
that i want to take you back with a few
last questions about yourself
starting out from your childhood what
really fascinated you as a kid
so i think um
as a kid i was always inspired by
greatness in sports
so i grew up in jerusalem
playing basketball in the streets of
jerusalem playing for a team called
acairushalaim
so uh i took it very seriously i never
made it to the pros because i you know
probably i wasn't that amazing i was
quite good but uh my inspirations were
like people like in in jerusalem like
football players like elio hannah or
malmilian back in the 80s
and then taking me to my you know
teenage years so michael jordan
you know was my my idol
and um
and there is one sentence that michael
jordan once said that i always take with
me
michael jordan was asked i mean michael
why do you give your heart and soul
every game
every season every practice i mean
you're michael jordan
the world technologies that you're the
best of the best why do you give your
best when you play against atlanta hawks
on the game game 72 in the season when
no one cares you're already the
champions or you made it to the playoffs
why do you care so michael jordan said
um because in any stadium where i play
there is a kid somewhere that they've
never seen me playing and for this kid
i'm scoring 35 points
so um i take that sentence as a as an
inspiration and i try to apply it in the
way we we play this game here at pantera
whenever we go whenever we do a pov
whenever we hire an employee this guy
for the marginal guy
for the marginal partner the marginal
investor or the marginal customer they
haven't seen us in action yet so it's so
i kind of take this analogy it's very
strong
i mean
i think that
and you also answered my next question
about what inspires you today and um and
and i think i'm gonna steal this from
you and i'm gonna i'm gonna borrow it
and i'm gonna do it in peril too from
now on i think it's i i didn't know that
that quote and i and i it's really
inspirational but what i do want to know
is three words that you would use to
describe yourself
a family man
my three kids you know guy knowing your
tom
uh and my wife dafna you know they're
giving it the energy and the happiness
and the inner energy to continue because
as ceos it's quite lonely sometimes
and you need some energy from
a different source which isn't arr or
renewal rate or investors or customers
so it's my family which is the core of
you know what i what what defines me
so beyond everything without them this
is nothing there cannot be a pantera
without them
thank you very very much stay safe stay
healthy best of luck with pantera thank
you for helping enterprises stay safe at
the end they're they're keeping us safe
and so thank you very very much take
care thank you thank you michelle all
the best